although we usually see the shadow as an
integral part of our existence most of
us are willfully blind to this existence
our dark side is concealed or
camouflaged in a painful attempt to
protect an image that fits the narrative
we decide to espouse through social
conditioning we come to construct a
facade that can keep the substrate of
our constructed identity stable so that
we can keep feeling safe every aspect of
our unconscious identity that cannot
morph into conscious judgment will
perpetually impede our progress as
individuals for it is creating a
fantastic world that cannot synchronize
with the frequencies of the real world
in such a landscape the real world or at
least whatever we can understand of it
becomes a negotistical Battleground that
leads to Collision and Madness